Hello. Hello. Hello. Welcome, Eric. Hey.
How's it going? Pretty good, David.
Awesome.
So we are here today.
We are gonna take a look at a
couple of technologies that I'm a big, big
fan of, and I think you started playing
with recently too, which is SaltStack
on PacketHost with a lot about Pulumi throwing
in.
So
we work together at PacketHost. Right? And I
think
we've we've kind of I think I've mentioned
SaltStack a few times and piqued your curiosity.
Do you wanna just give us a little
bit of background there?
Just a second. I got I get confused
here for a moment. Ah, okay. No problem.
Can you rewind can you rewind fifteen seconds?
I had another audio stream accidentally playing. Was
was hearing the broadcast of our thing. It's
like, wait a second. I've heard that before.
Yeah. Yeah. No worries. So I was just
telling the people that are tuning in.
We worked together a packet host. I've been
there about six weeks. I think maybe a
little bit longer now. During that time, I've
been yapping on about SaltStack once or twice.
I think your interest got a little bit
peaked and you started to take a look
at that yourself. So
Yeah. So
using
SaltStack
myself to manage
what I call a menagerie of little home
systems,
Raspberry Pis and jets and nanos and the
like.
I've I've run it
once sort of in production.
I wanna say sort of in production because
we were using it, but it was not
driving,
most of things.
And I'm just curious
as to,
how
especially,
it can be useful to
paper over some of the differences when you're
managing a network of heterogeneous systems.
Machines I have in my home lab,
some run Ubuntu, some run Debian,
Ubuntu
18,
Ubuntu 20.
I I spun up a net b free
BSD machine.
I plan to put a CentOS machine in
there somewhere. So just like the the the
mix of systems
that you might each want to individually experiment
on,
but yet you will still wanna run the
whole
the whole mass as if it was one
one
unit and not a whole bunch of individual
machines.
Excellent.
I'm sure we could do that. So what
I
let me kinda let me share my screen.
Let's just get started. I think the best
thing to do is just kind of start
with where we're starting from. Right? So I
did do a small session on provisioning packet
servers with Pulumi and
bootstrapping the cluster with SaltStack and kind of
just left it there. The the left the
rest of it was left with the resource
imagination.
And I wanna close that gap today. So
what I prepared in advance is really just
creating this empty packet project.
We have no servers currently available. However, we
do have the codes from last time, which
I will quickly run you through.
We'll get that kicked off and deploying, and
then we'll talk about how we can leverage
some of Salt's really
cool and unique features to, you know, to
manage all those servers with a single API,
which I think is really important and and
kind of from what you've said there.
So
with regards to the Pulumi code, I'm using
TypeScript. One of the really cool things about
Pulumi is you get to use the language
of your choice as long as it's supported.
It supports TypeScript, Go.
There's some dot net support,
Python support, and maybe one or two others.
For me, I like TypeScript, so we're gonna
go with that. And what this code does
is
it will create a salt master and a
single minion. I I think one of the
first things we should do is just change
the setup to be more
diverse and reflective of what you had in
your head with regards to operating system and
even hardware
differences.
So let's see what we have.
This is the code that spends up the
salt master.
And you can see from this block of
code here that it is provisioning a new
device on packet.
And Amsterdam One,
a c two medium with Debian nine.
So I think what we do for our
menus is try to have a nice
variety that did not reflect this.
If we come into I think we'll need
to change our menu and code a little
bit, but that's alright. I don't mind a
better life coding.
So our menu and code currently
hard codes the same values.
Have we assumed that we want to change
this, do you think changing the plan and
the operating system and and doing a few
varieties of those is enough to kind of
Yeah. It sort of gives gives the the
the flavor for it.
Awesome.
I would suggest
well, let's see. So in in my experiment
back
up a little bit. In my experiments, there
are differences between Debian and Ubuntu
in terms of package management.
They're not usually
they're not usually great until you run into
them unexpectedly.
The real challenges
get to be as you get further from
those two systems.
You know, package names changes,
tooling changes a little bit. So
what what what plan should we pick?
Yeah. Let okay. Let's start with that then.
So let's Yeah. I mean, I should know
these off the top of my head. I
must say I'm really bad at that. So
let's just use the UI where possible.
I think we took it all complete with
Fulume. And the reason I'm not gonna use
it right now is just because it doesn't
currently check the availability.
So, you know, I can pick some, but
I have had issues where I say, you
know, I want an m one extra large,
and it's just not been available. So it's
it's nice to come in here and just
confirm in real time what we've got. So
how about a c one large arm?
Sure. I think we take a couple of
boxes there, don't we? Yep.
And operating system on arm, we've got
Pick a Ubuntu, I think, because it'll provision
fast.
K.
I guess it's been to eighteen o four.
Now
let's we're gonna add another menu, so I'm
just gonna make these configurable as well. So
we'll pass in a plan
and
a operating system.
And then we'll reference these down here.
And
that just means that we can oh, it'll
just make it a bit easier for us
to spin up more,
assuming I learn how to type.
Okay.
So if I pop back to our index,
when we create this here, we need to
then specify
plans,
skew on large,
and operating systems.
And we were gonna go with them to
18 o four.
And then we can copy and paste this,
and we can create two more machines.
So I'll call this stop menu in one,
two,
three.
And it's formatted a bit nicer for me.
Cool. How about we spin up the
let's get something
so the c one arm has
one SSD,
two gigabit disks,
ThunderX processor.
Yep.
So and what was our first device?
First one was a c c one large
arm with Ubuntu.
You wanna do a c one small?
So our master Yeah.
It's an AMD. So why don't we grab
the c on here
for something just a bit different? S one
large. Exit.
Yep. That's a storage server, so that's got
a
whole bunch of storage on it. And what
was the other suggestion you made?
A c one small.
Got it. That's a good workhorse machine. Alright.
So let's see. Storage machine, let's run.
Let's look at all the operating systems.
How brave are we feeling?
FreeBSD?
Is that gonna work on FreeBSD? Don't know.
So
as soon as I seen that, I knew
you were gonna mention it.
So if we take a look at the
menu and user data,
we will need to just tweak this a
little bit so that it works on free
s free BSD.
Right.
As long as we know how to install
Salt on the previous device. You know what?
We can make this
Salt provides something called Salt Bootstrap.
Right.
A very helpful script that takes care of
the whole install process.
Yeah. So we don't necessarily need to hard
code it the way I have to use
package managers.
So
as long as we've got machines with curl
on it,
I don't really foresee any problem with just
dropping in the code like this. Yeah. Except
I think on free BSD, that tool is
not curl.
There's something called fetch there.
Maybe
that's maybe that's in the advanced challenge.
The advanced challenge. Well, I'm gonna add the
free SD box, but we'll maybe add another
one just in case that we got Yeah.
Just We've got we've we've got three. I
think we'll be okay. Let's do it. Have
a brief okay. So
user data room, we'll use this and free
STP and free BSD fails, we can SSH
up to that machine, quickly run software and
strap manually and fix this out there.
Alright.
Which means we need to pop back to
here.
So let's make menu in two of that.
You happy with the storage one being free
BSD? Do you foresee any problems there?
The only thing I can think of is
that it might take longer to boot.
So it might end up being
the last one that comes up. Yeah. That's
okay. We'll deal with that then.
Okay. So the last machine is a c
one small. So let's just make sure we
get an accurate
Yeah. If you can put a
the
try
I know you had Ubuntu 18 for one
of them.
I didn't see Ubuntu 20 in the drop
down, so I don't know if that's a
matter of
provider not knowing about it yet. Yeah. I
think the provider just doesn't up to date
with the latest versions.
I think we found us another session we
can do where we update the provider.
Yeah.
How about we do CentOS then? Guess it's
a good mix of operating systems.
Yeah.
CentOS
seven. Okay.
So we can run this now.
Hopefully, we don't run into any problems.
Can I set the project ID anywhere?
Yes. You did.
Go ahead. Platform.
Project ID.
Cool.
So
I think there's just a little bit of
configuration that I need then.
Yeah. So we just need to set
the project
name and organization ID. Okay. So contact
set
project
name.
I called it Rawkode
folks back and
organization
k. And
I can grab this from
here.
Alright.
Let's see how happy it So it's gonna
try and attempt.
Oh, it's gonna create a project.
That's
okay. Let's just give it a a unique
name then.
Let's say no. I forgot that it creates
a project. Oh, create from scratch.
Yep.
Okay. So it's gonna create a project. It's
gonna create a master
device and 3,000,000 devices.
And assuming my API token is incorrect, we're
good. The project is now created. So if
I refresh this page
when the first thing gets created, there's always
this, like, sigh of relief because I know,
like, if anything goes wrong, it's definite it's
flexible from this point forward. So Yeah. There's
our project.
We can see the master is on its
way.
So this will take, I guess,
five minutes. Minutes. Yeah. Well, hopefully, less than
five minutes. Potentially, up to five minutes.
But we can take a look at some
of the other stuff that's going on in
this repository
just to get a an understanding of what's
going on. So this platform object is just
something that I do, I think, in every
Pulumi project. And it and really just a
wrapper around the configuration
to make things a little bit easier. And
it also applies types to the configuration too.
But, you know, just by doing this, I
can say, hey. This and then I pass
it around everywhere I go. So you can
see here,
we run get platform.
We grab the name, and then we pass
platform into all of these functions, which are
used as helpers to then provision new infrastructure.
If I take a look at the salt
master, which we've already kind of
picked that, it just creates a device. Something
that's really cool about Pulumi
is I'm using
NPM to pull in dependencies to also make
my life a bit easier.
So you can see I'm not sure if
you're familiar with Mustache, but it's a templating
language for node. Yeah.
And it just means that I can keep
my user data provisioning script at its own
file with its own name and its own
syntax highlighting.
And where needed, I can interpolate using mustache.
We could just see that I'm dropping in
some Python code as well, which is available
here.
So I like this setup. It works really
well.
Now let's talk about this Python code thing.
So
one of the
the really cool concepts within SaltStack
is it has
something called a grain.
And a grain is a piece of metadata
or information or a key value pair
that is
specific to
one of the minions.
And
packet also has this metadata endpoint here,
which could be called from any of our
devices,
and it returns the metadata about the hardware
and the software and all of our SM
PCs too, and the the back end of
this stuff.
SaltStack
doesn't support us out of the box, but
because Salt is in Python and it's relatively
easy to extend, like, and under
what's that? Under 18 lanes of Python, I
was able to just consume that API and
then make these grains available.
The the use case may not be completely
apart yet, but once we get onto one
of these machines, we can actually realize that
we can use the facility,
the plan, the class, the IQN, and ID
as targets
when we're trying to query our menu.
And this is the tags as well. So
it's worth while thinking
through,
Salt has some terminology
that's unique to salt.
Grains are unique to the machine,
but there's also
pillars.
I I I I admit to being a
little bit
flummox sometime
sometimes just figuring out exactly which is which.
Like, some things are
you can query a node based on, for
instance, its operating system.
Right?
You can you can query a node or
or
act on a node,
based on
data that's stored on that node or data
that's stored on
the master.
Yep.
So let me I'll dive into that a
little bit then. You know, if anything is
unclear, just
just prod me. So Yeah.
You're right. The grains are specific to each
of the menus. So that's a device in
our case here. So a server is going
to the grains will expose the operating system,
the processes, the number of desks, the types
of desks,
the kernel version,
all of that stuff. All the stuff that
is used to describe that menu.
The pillars, on the other hand, are usually
either hard coded or
provided to the master
or come from a third party data source.
So there's actually many different sources for pellet
data. You can use Postgres. You can use
MongoDB.
You can use, you know, managed cloud services
like s three or, you know, RDS.
And There's so many. In fact, let's just
close this up.
It's all pillars.
If we go to the documentation
here,
I think this link
and click on pillar modules. So these are
all of the modules which support exposing pillar
data to the master.
So you can see because your blob storage,
you can execute arbitrary commands as long as
they output JSON or YAML,
then small will parse that and make that
available.
Cobbler is for bare metal provisioning and some
other provision management stuff, which is really cool.
Console can be used.
What else?
Etcd,
straight up fail stuff.
You can consume impeller information from a GET
repository, which I quite like doing as well.
As well as the command stuff, you can
use HTTP APIs to pull out anything that's
JSON or YAML as well. There's Mongo, MySQL.
So, you know, there is lots of different
sources.
And
the use case for the most of these
is generally for data that is considered almost
secret or at least it can be secretive.
So it's not gonna be provisioned through the
standard means like we're doing now. Like, if
you can imagine, well, this is all in
Git.
And and I in theory, I could make
this all public. There's nothing secret in this
repository.
And the pillars would be that place where
secret information could come from.
But I want to
have c bundles
or certificate authorities or private keys or or
just plain old secrets. I could have them
involved and then have Salt speak to Vault
to pull that information and the pillar data.
That makes sense? That makes sense.
Good.
It's been a while since I've tried to
explain greens and colors, so hopefully hopefully, we're
good.
The user data is only slightly different
for the the master dominion setup here. So
the
the good thing I expand that with Debbie
and because I never changed it. But it's
installing the salt master and the minion. So
that's another kind of cool thing about salt
is that, you know, the salt master can
also run its own minion and it can
have this sort of self referential bit strap
process or provisioning or high state as salt
would call it.
We need to grab the local IP.
We use this just to bind the interface
that salt listens on. So we're talking to
we're trying to keep this secure,
you know, all of our packet devices. And
I think you'll need to correct me here.
I think they all, by default, launch with
a public IPv four, a private IPv four,
and an IPv six address.
That's correct. Yeah. So we don't want our
salt master listening on our public IPv four
address because,
unfortunately, remote code execution is a thing.
So we want to trust only our private
network.
What else do we do? We just tell
it where the master is. So rest is
us configuring the salt master as its own
menu, so we just have to drop in
that the master is available on the local
device IP address.
And then we provision the packet metadata. So,
like, extend and salt could not be easier.
You literally just have to drop in a
Python script, enter the right location on the
device,
and magically, it's available to us to call.
Really
simple.
Gotcha.
And our menu one is easy. I mean,
we've just I just copied two lanes from
a something off of GitHub and dropped it
into this. What could go wrong?
What could possibly go wrong?
So the the cluster that I have
adds another
complication to things because
oh, looks like something came up.
Because the
the devices are not all in the same
packet network.
So I'd I'd in my configuration, I do
not have
the ability to just use the packet private
net 10 address.
So what I did for that was took
advantage of the fact that I'm using Tailscale,
which is a VPN
network.
And I do the same kind of binding
except I bind it to the Tailscale address
instead of the public address.
And that way that way I have
bootstrapping is harder because you have to bootstrap
Tailscale first before you boot SaltStack,
but you have this sort of same idea
of a
private management address
to to connect things through.
Very cool. I like it.
I've never really considered using Tailscale to kinda
provide a backbone for
disparate sources or networks and keeping them all
in the same salt network, but that's a
really cool concept.
Yeah.
Yeah. It's been it's been going reasonably well.
I I
don't
know how I would debug it all if
I didn't have out of band access to
everything.
Right? I got out of band access to
the packet machines. I've got a little breakout
box that I can plug into pies if
I need to. Like, most of the stuff
here could be scrapped and restarted if I
had to.
But just having a
a management channel,
it's really handy.
Yeah. For sure. I can see that.
Alright. So let's understand. You're right there. You
said something has come up. So another thing,
Terraform and Pulumi both do this, but they
actually build a a graph of dependencies
when they parse all of the resources that
the automation is supposed to create. Because our
minions have a dependency on the master, I
e, they need to know the IP address,
That was created first in isolation,
and then we pop back over here. Yeah.
We'll see those other machines coming up.
And then these were all created in parallel
because all of those dependencies are satisfied, which
was just the master. The menu three was
the fastest.
Our Ascentos
seven box was pretty quick at coming up.
We're now just waiting on our free BSD
and our Ubuntu machine.
But there's nothing stopping us
going and kicking the tires on this master
against targets. Yep.
So pop open a new tab.
And let's do
Rich.
Yes, please.
Well, you'd be key.
There we go. Okay. So we are now
on
master one.
Let's just confirm
that
everything worked as expected.
Yep.
Yeah. I have a master
running and the minions
minion is running. There are multiple processes, but
that's not
important right there.
So how can we confirm our configuration?
Well, first, we're gonna go to slash e
c c slash salt.
We will just confirm our menu was configured
as we expected.
You can see our master IP address was
set,
and we also did some master configuration
where we bound
the internal IP address. So I'm very confident
at this stage that the provisioning was successful,
which means
we can begin to interact with Salt. Now
no minions have matched the target.
That's expected. That wasn't me just making a
mistake.
So we do we do have our salt
master running. We do have a salt menu
running. Our salt menu knows how to speak
to the salt master, but we have not
approved
the keys.
Okay.
Now what Salt does
when you install it, it it will generate
it will generate some certificates which are used
to authenticate with
the the master machine.
So our menu generates the certificate. It sends
its key to the master. We have to
actually explicitly approve that. There's our step to
automate it, not something that I think we'll
be able to cover in this session.
But for now, what we can do is
tell it to accept master
one.
Like so.
And then if we run salt key one
more time,
we now have our accepted key.
Now I do have one small concern right
now.
Is that I expected
to see menu three listed here because The
CentOS machine. Yeah.
So I'm assuming the salt bootstrap on this
machine potentially failed.
Right. So should we go quickly take a
look at that? Yep. So let's take a
look and see what see what's going on
there.
Okay. So yes. Press my key.
Alright.
So Salt is installed because the directory exists.
My configuration
is the default menu in conf.
It doesn't generate keys.
Alright. Let's see what's going.
And it's not running. It's not running.
But it looks like the command is available.
No one supports Python two.
Yes.
Okay.
So
that means
DNS
install.
I mean, let's try the naive approach. Is
it not DNS? That must be YAML on
Sentinel. YAML.
So I'm just gonna run this manually
run the
can I remove
no? I'll install. Remove
Python two.
This
is CentOS
seven?
Yeah. It's quite it's quite an older version,
isn't it? Yeah.
So I wonder if the thing to do
is to uninstall SaltMinion
entirely
and then
reinstall it from the boost transcript.
I
don't know what the package is called. Oh,
so I may have installed it through pep
pep
uninstall.
And maybe that's a problem because it may
not have been using pep three. I may
have just used pep pushes pep two
PET where is that?
Yeah. 2.7.
So if we do a PET uninstall,
so manual or make just be solved.
There we go.
Pep three install.
That should get us running. Yeah.
Python.
I would have expected SaltBootstrap
to handle that, to be honest. Yeah. I
would have expected it to.
What didn't work there?
I have to access this salt call
pet install
salt. Nope.
That's weird.
I
have
I have all the other commands.
Why is salt menu not working?
Good question.
Which salt menu?
User
oh, wait. Wait. So SSH.
Yeah. Okay.
I mean, that looks alright.
Alright. Fine. It's Python three.
Is Python three installed?
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Okay. It's working now if I do that
very explicitly.
That's weird.
Let's just quickly what happens with user Ben?
So that's the wrong path. Let's log in.
That's the wrong path. Yeah. Yeah.
When in doubt,
log out.
Hey.
Okay.
So Okay.
Now There's a past issue. I am gonna
believe if we take a look at our
cloud and it log
that our provisioning step, because we never installed,
Let's just pull that up.
I'm assuming this failed, which means we never
created our config.
So let's just do that manually as well.
We'll get there. So menu.d,
we'll copy this from another machine.
Oh, that's
You got the wrong one. Or
It's alright. We'll grab the IP from here.
So Yeah.
Let's pop over here. Go to our salt
configuration.
We want to go to menu.d,
and we want to do
master.com.
And if we
run system d
star,
so
will that work?
Daemon reload.
So I'm just using the wrong path too.
It's using the wrong path too. That must
just be something weird with the way it
installed.
Alright. Let's modify here we go to file.
I'm committing to fixing it now. I feel
like I need to get it.
A system d how do you get the
is it described?
No.
Endful?
I can't remember.
I can't remember. Describe
a unit fail.
Alright. Wait. You can do status.
I'm not sure remember the unit fail.
Cannot be found.
Here.
Oh, what did I do?
Oh,
them.
User local.
Oh.
Let's try a daemon reload.
Star install
menu.
Hey. No errors.
Right.
Okay. Wow.
Wow. So I
think the moral of that story is that
the
older the version
of the operating system you are running, the
more likely it is you will have to
intervene.
Oh, yeah. For sure. And I didn't realize
sorry. I wasn't we had a someone drop
in the comments there and try to help
us out, Bradley. Oh, hey, Bradley.
Says we could do hats.
So I've never had done that before.
Ah, that is so cool. Thank you. Awesome
tip. Yeah.
Right. Okay. So
that's running. So let's run our salt key.
And we have menu three. We Hey. It's
fair. But we don't have menus one and
two. So I think
we're gonna be fixing those as well. Hopefully,
it's the same problem and we can fix
it relatively quickly.
But for now, let's just accept minion
three.
Okay.
We will fix those other two notes, but
let's try and cover a couple of basics
of salt then.
So let's
the first salt command I I think anyone
should run
is
test dot ping.
And let's just cover the two syntax that
you'll see online for this command.
Mhmm.
This
this tripped me up when I was first
learning. That's all. And it's so simple, but
I'll cover it anyway. Is that the star
gets expanded by your shell,
by bash or zed shell or fish.
So you don't need to just wrap it
in single quotes or escape it.
And that's why you can't just do star.
Yeah. It'll have It always bug me. Always
bug me.
But the test stop ping is the the
simplest command. All all it does is
try to establish if the salt minions are
online.
And you can see that the two that
we've managed to successfully accept and provision,
they are online. So
so now what can we do?
How about some executing remote commands? Doesn't that
sound? Sure.
What what would you like to know about
our machines, or what commands do you want
me to run?
One
of the things that I will normally do
when logging into a machine will be run
something like
uptime to see how long it's been up
or who to see who's else is on
the system, if there is anyone else in
the system.
Yeah. Great commands. I use those commands all
the time as well.
Let's run who?
We can see me
fixing menu and
we can run uptime.
We can see both our machines have been
alive for less than twenty minutes, which makes
sense.
Yep.
Now right now, we've been targeting every machine.
So why don't we kinda cover the different
targeting options that are available?
So
let's try
targeting by name.
Simple.
Yep.
And you can use you can use star
in that configuration. Right? So you could target
if your minions were all named the same,
you could solve
Indeed.
Is that what you meant? Yeah. That's exactly
what you meant.
Yeah. So the the name matcher is the
default one.
We're not passing any
parameters to there. You know, the star is
is also just doing a a name match
here. It's just saying match everything. We can
prefix our postfix. It depend on how we
wish to match. If I wanted to match
all of the
three devices, then I guess I could do
that too.
But Salt has just so much more power
when it comes to matches.
And there's a lot of documentation on this,
actually.
So targeting
so
before we look at the targeting options, let's
just see information we can pull out, and
then we'll look at how we can actually
use that information to target it.
And let's see if I can remember the
commands.
So
we can interact with the grains subsystem for
salt by using grains dot. You can see
how I use test dot ping.
I use command
Run,
and I can use grains.blah.
I
believe we can run grains.ls.
There we go.
Yep.
And this is all of those key value
pairs that we were talking about at the
start. This is all the grain data that
we can use for
targeting
and our interstate files or even just on
the command side. So
let's see.
Let me see what kernel we've got.
Sure.
More info, please.
Let's do
kernel relief.
There we go.
But we have a Linux kernel of 4.9.
And let's see what we've got running on
our order sent off box.
Oh, dear.
Oh,
wow. My museum colonel.
Yeah. So
we can,
assuming,
we maybe wanted to get salt to profession
some sort of oh, I don't know why
settings decided to on Teams. There we go.
No.
I love how I'm on do not disturb
mode and Teams doesn't really care.
Let's just Take one take one from the
team.
Let's just close Teams. Go away, Teams. Alright.
So if we wanted to say you assaulted
provision kernel models or something, then that targeting
might be really important.
So we could use the menu name, grains,
and other information to target our menus. So
let's take a look at the docs.
I mean, this page is is relatively big.
There's a lot there's a few different It's
a lot there. Yeah. There's when it comes
to targeting, there's a lot you can do.
We'll look at a couple of them just
now, and then we'll try and get on
to something a bit more fun. But, you
know, you could do a straight up green
match. So let's run this.
Alright. So this isn't gonna return anything because
we don't have a grain that matches,
but we do have
center.
Ta da.
And we're just returning the SaltStack
version.
So the way the grade matcher works is
we put the key on the left of
the colon and then the value on the
right of the colon.
And I believe
the star may work.
Yeah. Okay.
Yeah.
We can also do
compound matchers
where we can specify
and we have to use the docs for
the syntax, but I believe it's green at
center.
Nope.
Capital g.
And compact matches allow us to use more
than one match
here.
I believe we can say and
use another grain where kernel is a little
in it,
like so.
So the compound matcher allow you to use
grains or menu names
together.
They're relatively painless syntax. It's not
not too difficult.
Note groups. I
don't think we'll cover note groups today. But
note groups can be configured in the salt
configuration.
You could, like like, if something isn't available
as a grain, like, maybe you wanna do
something that's more Rawkode aware, then you could
configure that for note groups.
What else is cool? We're not playing with
pillars yet.
Yeah. You can do subnet and IP address
matching, which is quite cool too.
But if you just want it, maybe your
data center is actually maybe you don't need
to go down the node groups for your
Rawkode or stuff because you've got your network
configured and the IP address is allocated on
a a per rack basis.
I don't know. There's loads.
Yeah. The the the
simple commands are very easy to describe,
and the
complexity is there as well.
Like, if you really need to do something
special. Because you can tag
like, if you need to work on a
arbitrary
group of machines, you can tag a group
of machines as a list too. Right?
Yes.
Yes. So let's let's talk about that. That's
a really good point. Thank you.
We've provisioned our machines with our packet metadata
module.
Right.
Same one we had in Versus Code.
So what does that mean? Well, let's do
go in the
which
of these is
packet stuff? Facility. Facility?
Didn't pick it up?
Uh-oh.
Let's do facility.
Dress?
Why did I pick it up?
Let's just make sure I haven't broken the
scripts.
Yeah. That's good.
Let's run.
So we can
there is a sec step involved, which I
thought was automated, but we can try doing
this now. So we do
I'm not gonna remember how to do it.
Salt,
util,
think all.
There we go. There we go.
And you can see now it's picked up
that green. So I guess that's just something
I have to clean up in the automation.
And it just tells it to kinda scan
those direct those expected directories for new module
types. And there's loads of module types. You
know, we can have states, we can have
beacons, we can have different engines.
Ah, loads.
Okay. So let's run
grains.la.
Then let's just correct.
It's really not gonna show up.
How about get facility?
What
am I doing wrong?
Version of Python?
It's weird that it showed up in the
sync.
It doesn't show up now. It definitely did
sync that time. Did something. Yeah. Yeah.
Normally, I'd see a dot PYC
file here
to show that it compiled.
I'm gonna just restart Salt.
That is Yeah.
Grins.get
facility.
Still no help, you know, sir. Yeah. You're
letting me down. So
Let's check the log. I wouldn't waste too
much time on it. We don't need to
work on the packet metadata today,
But, you know, I I also don't like
things not working.
That looks like metadata.
Yeah. It did
the metadata API.
Yeah.
Is an error message hiding somewhere in that?
Or
I wonder if I should be worried about
this.
It's not my MacBook.
That's the packet metadata. So you're in a
project that's shared with other people.
And by default,
the
metadata includes all the metadata from the
entirety of everyone who has access to that
project.
Alright. Okay. Cool.
I
was slightly worried, Harrison. I don't think we
exposed any key to tokens or anything. No.
There's no keys. Those are public. Those are
public.
Yeah. Okay.
It does appear. So I'm just doing something
wrong,
I'm sure.
As well as
l s, there is
get.
Oh,
no. There's
help me salt.
Salt grains
command.
I got some recipes as well.
So
grains.ls.
That's what I was thinking of.
That's the same as oh, l s is
what I was doing.
Yeah. Items items is what I want.
Let me see what we have.
Ah, it's under a key.
It's under a key.
Of course.
Okay. Phew.
And there was me thinking nothing more.
So
there you go. We can call packet dot
metadata,
and if I add facility,
I
can't remember the stop syntax, but it's there.
Okay. Good.
So we can use those grains if we
wish to
target things with
commands.
Right. So we could say, for instance, do
this command on all
hosts in AMS one.
Yes.
Yeah. I think so.
Okay. So that means I need to remember
how to get the sub key then. So
let's try it. So
we're gonna do a green match.
We're gonna look for the packet
metadata.
Yeah. It's cool on. I just popped into
my head there. I'm sure.
Yeah.
Oh, no.
I've removed the command. Okay. So we can
do a grain matcher.
Let's say we do a command dot run.
We will run.
Yeah, we'll just we'll run here.
We wanna match on our packet metadata
on the facility
Times one.
There.
Here.
Perfect. It's all coming back to me. Feeling
the pressure.
So What about pillars?
It mostly works the same.
Might not spell pillars right.
There we go.
And but we don't have anything configured as
a source of pillar data.
But I guess we've got a few things
we can we can do now.
Good. You wanna take a look at the
list of provision machines and see if we
got another
like, do a salt keys and see if
there's another one that's ready to to pop
in.
No. But we will Nothing?
We can, correctly. Oh, wait. We never got
a minion too.
The free BSD failed.
Yeah. The free BSD failed.
Alright.
But we can fix
a bit.
I keep doing that. I keep go screen
I just split the screen.
Alright. Okay. Yes, please. You, Ricky.
And
let's see how far this one got. So
exact same problem with a printer in the
center.
Okay. So pet uninstall.
Salt. Goodbye. Bye.
Eventually.
Thinking about it.
There we go.
Yes, please.
Let's do PEP three install
vault.
Python PEP three.
I think.
And we just got install on this Questions.
I don't know what's going on with Salt
Bootstrap then. Maybe it's not
been updated since the 03/2001
release. I'm not really sure.
It's not important.
Let's get Salt working. We'll register it, and
then we'll talk about what we can do.
So we can begin to add file routes,
though, and Salt a file route is somewhere
that has configuration that we want our salt
master to configure or consume,
which allows us to provide power information or
our state information, and we'll see how we
can actually build states.
I think the other thing that you wanted
to cover was what if we wanna install
NGINX across these disparate operating systems where the
package name may be different, but we can
tackle that too.
K.
Alright. So PIP three,
install.
Oh.
And let's grab this IP address again.
So do you wanna talk a little bit
about,
Zero and Q and how Salt works behind
the scenes,
Or is that advanced?
Or do I should
is sufficiently
advanced for another time.
No. Let's let's talk about what goes on
there.
I think it's it's important. So if we
talk about what happens
when I run something as
as innocent as this command. So
when I run Salt with my targeting and
some sort of module to run,
it's important to know that the master
does not communicate with any of the minions.
No message is sent
over a TCP stack to the minions,
at least directly.
What actually happens and that's really simplified it
from a security point of view as well,
particularly
around firewall rules,
is that the only firewall rules you need
to allow are your minions to speak to
your to your master.
And that's because when we issue a command
here,
what actually happens is the salt master rates
to a zero m q topic,
and there's one spare pair of menu, and
I think it is.
And those menus reach out to the master
and subscribe to their topics.
So we put the instruction onto CRM queue.
The menus pick it up. They do the
work,
and then a message gets published back on
CRM queue, the master consumes it to understand
that the job is done.
And that's it.
It's it scales super well. Like, if you
can imagine that I've got I mean, that's
either a contrived example right now. We've only
got a couple of minions, but Azure infrastructure
scales to dozens to hundreds to thousands.
Those messages been written to a local CRM
queue and consumed downstream.
It's super fast.
Yeah. It means that the network infrastructure can
be simplified as well because
if you have a
minion
that's
remote,
right, it's in an edge location, it's behind
a firewall, whatever,
you don't need to
send command
you don't need to send something directly to
it. It can fetch from a
more publicly reachable site.
Yeah. Definitely.
Yeah.
So
that's taken a little bit longer than I
was expecting.
Is this on our is this on our
c one large arm?
I think this is on our arm machine.
So
Yeah. So there's a story behind this.
Up until recently,
the
PIP infrastructure
for wheels
on ARM
has been lagging behind. And so
in a lot of cases, we're actually compiling
things right now.
Whereas on a x 86 machine, they would
just be available.
Yeah. So I guess it would use a
precompiled version, but for ARM, we have to
drill that as we We have to do
all the work ourselves. Yeah.
Alright. Well, we can leave that running for
now.
So
now we understand how the messaging works. We
kinda covered the what that means for our
networking security point of view, at least as
far as firewall rules go.
Next, I guess, wanna
provision something.
Right? Right. We we wanna install some software.
Alright. So let's see. What do we have
again?
OS.
Alright. We got a Debian box and a
CentOS box.
So let's search on the this is a
Debian box.
I don't wanna pick something, but the package
name is the same. Although, I guess, could
because it's still really even if the package
names are the same,
it's still using a different package manager under
the hood to install it. So that's cool.
Right. There's also stuff we can do, but
passing in, like
Salt uses
Ginger
templating a lot, and you can use maps
and Ginger to provide dynamic
package name, which is quite nice.
Yeah.
Okay. So they're the same, but that's fine.
So what we can do,
you got a suggestion there? Or No. I
I think this is a I think it's
good to show off that
you can run one command that'll
do
do different things on different systems that are
logically the same, but underneath the code underneath
the hood, they're they're different. Oh, yeah. Definitely.
I think that you're you're right.
And before I run this, I think that
would just be that would be silly of
me not to kind of explain. So
we could do an act
search engine x with a command run. Right?
The problem being
being just me
I said,
it's not gonna work
on our infrastructure which isn't debbing or event
to base. Like, oh, that doesn't work. Which
means we can't do apt install engine access
way. Or I could, but it would only
work on a subset of my machine. And
what Salt does is provide state modules, which
try to abstract away most of this stuff.
Like, you you you just don't really care.
And we get this used package dot installed
and give it the name of a package.
I thought I would just check our ARM
box before I run this, but it's not
up yet.
And package
install.
And behind the scenes, that's installing those packages
for us on both of our machines.
Right. Then that that that is gonna be
a little bit verbose,
but
it's now done.
So how can I convince you that that
has actually happened?
Let's try
is there a package dot beraden? I can't
remember.
I think Yeah. Don't Here we go.
And we get slightly different versions of each
of them, which is to be expected.
Well, yeah. I mean, we didn't do anything
we didn't specify anything to conversions
or or anything like that. So we're getting
whatever's latest and greatest per operating system.
And it turns out that
CentOS is actually a few versions ahead even
though it's kernel was particularly old.
So
that's cool.
We can also I mean, we can trust
package dot version, but we can also do
a command dot run where we do NGINX
version. Oh, I think that works.
Oh,
there we go.
And we get that same information back by
the you know, directly speaking to the command
line.
Let's bring up this person too.
Let's do some army stuff.
Arm arm stuff.
Menuin.
I guess we're creating this ourselves.
Vim master con master
Grab the IP address again.
Restart
SaltMenion.
Alright.
So we run SaltKey.
Hey. Stop there.
There we go.
Patience. Here we go.
Opinion
one.
Thank you. Okay. So how you can
let
kernel
release.
Silly me. Okay.
Kernel release.
There
we go. Not one of them the same,
but I guess we expected that. Right? Yeah.
We expected that.
Well, let's And and and I'd I'd say,
you know,
that the fact that
we've had some hiccups
because of
different
operating systems and different
versions of things and whatnot.
You know,
on the one hand,
having some sort of diversity in your network
is useful
because because you get to see a bunch
of new
you get to see things that you wouldn't
see if they were all the same.
But there's a certain hassle factor to it.
And I I don't
you know, for for production,
I I've I very much understand
why someone would have a completely homogenous network
with as few differences between the nodes as
possible,
but this isn't production right now.
I guess it is.
Okay.
I lost my train of thought now. Oh,
let's let's
how can I check
the CPU architecture?
We wanna see the ARM machine. Right?
Yeah. The CPU
One of the arch maybe? CPU
arch maybe.
Yeah.
Cool.
Hey.
Working.
Alright.
Good. I feel better now. So
we used the state module to do a
package installation
across
three different operating systems, two different architectures,
and three different kernels as well. But that's
that's that's fine. So let's
take a look at that list. So we
looked at the power list earlier, but we
can also just change this to green
greens.
And we can take a look at, like,
there there's also why am I looking at
grains?
States.
There you go.
Alright. So state modules are the are the
things that we can do
with Salt.
Alright? And and by doing with Salt, I
mean, like, leverage their abstractions so that we
don't need to use command dot run for
everything.
I mean, don't get me wrong. If you
if you get Salt running in this fashion
and you're just using it for ad hoc
commands, like, salt
command or run is fantastic. But eventually, you're
gonna wanna
codify.
So state modules, let's see. We can provision
less encrypt certificates using Salt.
We can
configure Apache.
Find something fun.
Managing staff assault.
That sounds scary. Wow.
Yep.
We can manage our cron jobs. Let's take
a look at that. That'll be relatively
painless.
I see that now, and I bet you
I get it. I'll break it.
Anything jumping at you?
You wanna look at the file interface?
Yeah.
I guess that's probably one of the most
common configuration management tasks. Right? Is
I wanna get a fail onto all of
my machines. So
alright.
Let's take a look at the cron. Then
what I I like about Salt is that
the examples are particularly good in all of
their documentation.
Yeah.
So this will require us to write our
first state file as well. Cool.
So if I come to SRB
vault
and we have a directory here.
I can add a state directory,
and I can add my
add
cron
state.
And for doing that, we're just gonna use
the SLS extension,
which is like a salt state file extension,
which uses YAML, which is where all the
examples come in.
When we looked at the
the accessibility of Salt earlier, and there was
something called an engine,
and there's also renderers. You can actually write
your own renderer to take JSON or take
Markdown or take just Python code or whatever
and write your Salt space. I'm not sure
why you're going to do that, but the
accessibility is pretty cool.
So
there are two ways to write the salt
state as well.
From the present,
and I'll kinda cover both.
Let me just take a minute. Alright.
So Salt
allows you to let's see the explicit syntax.
This is the one I I tend to
prepare. And that means that we just use
some sort of arbitrary ID for the state,
which must be unique.
We then
then specify a module. So cron dot present,
we're using the cron state module and then
the function present to make sure that the
cron job exists. There are others. You can
see this list here.
I lost it up.
It's because I'm zoomed in too much.
We can do absent EMV present, EMV present,
fail, present so those are each of the
functions that are available to us.
The name is then what we actually want
to execute in a state. So I can
say date.
Yeah. We just wanna write the date and
output it to file, run it as a
root user, and run it, I guess, means
every five minutes.
The same syntax would be to a met
the name and use that as the ID,
which is also valid and
I'm just not a big fan of it.
So is it every five minutes or on
the fifth minute of the hour?
Yeah. That'll be the fifth minute of the
hour.
Let's take a look at the function header.
Minute, hour, day, month, month, day, week.
Yeah. Yeah. Okay. So that'll be the fifth
minute. If I wanted to do it every
five minutes, it would be what's that? I
can't remember. Star over five?
I can't remember.
Is it star over five or is it
five comma
zero comma five comma 10 comma whatever?
Yeah.
I think star let's try star over five
and see what happens. And then we'll to
the yeah. We'll take a look at the
cron tab and see what what it generates.
Let's just save that.
Now
if we do a salt
salt
what am I doing?
Oh, yeah. Okay.
Let's take a look at our salt master
configuration.
There's something called a fail root
here.
Surf salt. Yeah.
Where we could tell it how to consume
our
dates.
Yeah. It's Surf Salt. So let's move that
file. I don't think it
I guess it doesn't need the states.
Can't remember the last time I provisioned just
by hand.
Let's remove states.
And now we just got this in the
top level.
And let's just try and see what happens.
So that says run on
all machines state dot SLS, which is just
like
how I can tell Salt to run a
one off state
for this.
And we can tell it to run ad
cron.
Alright. And it did pick it up, but
it doesn't doesn't link my syntax.
And it may just be the may just
be a YAML thing.
There we go. There we go.
So now both of these
all three of these servers have some sort
of cron configured on it. So let's just
pick one.
We'll take a look on the CentOS machine.
And if I run Chrome tab, it's the
we've
got our star over five.
So every five minutes, it's gonna execute date
and write it to a file.
Easy. Right? Easy.
Okay.
What should we do next? You want me
to do a file. Right?
Yeah. Let's do a let's look at the
files.
No. For,
I mean
Let's ensure our directory exists first, and then
we'll maybe dump a file inside of it.
So
copy on our example. We'll modify it to
certain needs.
So we'll call this
let's create a let's just build on this
really contract cron example. Right? So Sure. Let's
do cron test output there.
We're gonna create a new directory for this
output instead of putting it under test.
And we need to add a name because
I don't like it being
taught. And we'll call this temp
live
stream
Chrome test.
Okay.
We'll configure this to write to that directory.
And we'll see it.
No. You you
let's look at that file again. You're writing
to
a file in the top one,
and is that a directory in the second
one? Yeah. There we go.
Good catch.
And then we can read from fresh in
all of our machines
except for one failed, which is, I guess,
good. And
what failed?
You do if you have make term minus
It didn't like to create the directory because
the subdirectory didn't exist.
Oh, no. It failed in the mall. Yeah.
You're right. And it's because of the subdirectory.
That's
my fault. Salt has a flag for that.
Make
there's I
think yeah.
Try again.
Nope. Let's confirm.
I think it would there's
there we go. Nature's.
That was close.
Run that again. Ta da. Ta da. Ta
can run temp
livestream
contest,
and it's not run yet. But it runs.
Hello?
Because we're doing a
present,
now it has created this twice.
And that's just because we changed the the
name.
Oh, sure. Reason.
So I I didn't realize that we got
rid of one another one. So let if
we just run that again, we shouldn't end
up with three. Shouldn't.
Yeah. Good.
Okay. What do we wanna do next? So
we created a directory.
Let's
hop over here, and we can do a
fail.
It's this no. No. Manage. Place to managed.
There's so many different functions and modules.
Okay.
So
let's I'm trying to break this down.
So we'll give it a explicit name.
We'll call this our
fake file.
We give it a name.
So temp
livestream
contest
pick,
and then we can provide some sort of
source. Now the way that the failed up
managed works is you can specify multiple sources,
then it'll stop on the first one that
exists.
Neither
of these exist
though.
So it should fail.
Well, unless we add one that works. Yeah.
Do
shall we see it fail first? Let's see
it fail first, sir. Alright.
Fail. Fail and fail. Nothing found.
Yep.
And because we don't have a source that
works, so let's come out here. Now we
can do salt,
SLS path, which is my favorite little thing,
and we'll call this fake.
Now this doesn't exist
still.
So, you know, if we run it, we're
gonna see a state of red again.
But that SLS path means that it's gonna
use the path from where this state file
is.
So, like,
I create fake and watch. I normally wouldn't
do it normally.
Let's clean this up. I feel like I'm
being quite messy right now. So let's say
we have our
livestream state,
And inside of that, we've got
our edit.sls,
which is a convenience helper.
Come into our livestream.
Let's use our setup, and we'll have our
normally, I have, like, a fails directory, and
then inside the fails, I'll have pick.
Hi.
I am a pick
fail.
Okay.
So we made a few changes there.
What we want to do now
is modify
this path
to be failed
pick.
And
my
command
there.
It's now livestreamed.
And we don't need to put
and I'll talk about how we
address our name states in just a second,
but I should be able to run this
as is, and it works.
Yep. And we we can confirm this here
with temp livestream
catfake.
So
really, really powerful.
We also have the ability to interpolate, but
let's let's cover the naming
first.
It's one of my favorite things about Salt.
I actually use Salt for my dot files.
I was gonna say keeping track of home
directories and whatnot.
Yeah. So
and the reason I do that is because
it means I can run individual
parts of my state really, really easily. So
if we take this as an example, we've
got a livestream state that runs in it
dot SLS when it's not when it's not
totally authorized. I can also add a one
off command dot SLS,
which could just do
cron
test one
off,
This is gonna do a command dot run.
We'll have it run who.
If I run our livestream state again,
there's no who.
However,
I can add oh, what do they call
it?
One off. I can add
one off like so, and it runs who
and all of the machine.
Now we have a full
array
of requisites and
includes helpers that we could use within Salt.
So, you know, I can do
includes
one off.
You need a dot to indicate it's the
local directory.
Otherwise, I would have to do
livestream
dot one off.
Let me get the eclipse one off.
And if I run
without that
oh, what did I get wrong?
It doesn't compare oh, hold on.
Not a dictionary.
I see that the documentation is handy.
It is good documentation.
It's include.
Of course.
And we now have, you know, this this
went up from three to four, but we
can see that it's it's now including
this who output as part of the state
run. And I can still individually run that
one off as well. Like, I don't need
to run the whole thing, and I think
that's just something I mean, I'm a big
fan of Ansible,
but it just doesn't have that level of
I can choose what I wanna be able
to do at top, which I really like.
There's also prerequisites that require some text.
So let's say prerequisites.
Here, you can see that it has dependencies.
And if we take a look at our
our edit state, you know, we
what happens with SaltStack here is it will
run this file from top to bottom and
order,
but you can also be very explicit about
the prerequisites
or requisites.
Mhmm. So we can say we actually require
the step to run
first.
Or, you know, the other options we've got
are
if something changes
or if a file changes, then I want
to ensure that the state runs again.
We can watch files. Like, there's a whole
bunch of stuff here that's really, really cool
that allows you to tie all your states
together.
I can now show one more thing, and
then we'll kinda have a chat and see
if you got any ideas.
So
inside fails,
I can open fake, and I can then
use this gender syntax,
or I can reference the group the grains
like so.
And
let's run.
That's okay.
can't Yeah. Didn't
And
didn't interpolate.
Yep.
Let
me see if I can remember why. Oh,
yeah. So
this is why I should do ad hoc
stuff. We need to tell it
I think it is
engine.
Let's confirm
that.
Failed or managed.
It's template, Ginger. There we go. Not engine.
We just tell her that we want to
template it.
And it's Ginger it's just Ginger. It's not
Ginger
It's not ginger two.
Thank you.
That's better. And you can see it it
actually shows you the change that I made.
So it removed the green's line Yeah. And
added our Linux line. And then I can't
Nice.
Good.
Cool. We're getting there. That's cool.
So you could see how this would be
useful
for
so one of the things that
that you can leverage the packet metadata for
is
inserting
SSH keys into,
home directories
because the packet metadata includes
SSH
public keys
for everyone who has access to things.
So you can imagine
provisioning a home directory for someone,
based
on just their
key information that you can pull from metadata.
Oh, really? I didn't know that. Okay. So
should we try and provision all of our
machines with
your SSH key?
Well, let's see if it's there.
So if I do Carl,
is that metadata.packet.net/
is that right? I think so.
Okay. So let's pipe us through j q.
Yep.
Let Salt install j q.
Package
install.
We'll do it on all of our machines.
Sure. Bring them all up.
Okay.
No.
Good.
But we pull up a curl,
type it to Jake here,
and let's just see if we can narrow
this down a little bit. So and then
we'll re pipe it.
That's a lot of keys there. So
Yeah. It's a lot of keys because you're
on a you're on a shared project. I
am on a shared project. Okay. SSH keys.
So
dot SSH
There
we go.
Now we've only got the keys.
It doesn't look like there is a way
to pull out individuals.
No. It does not. Oh, we could provision
them all. Right? We could provision them all.
We can just trust everybody.
Sure.
Okay. So what do we need to do
first?
We need to make someone a home directory.
Okay. First time to let's just I'm gonna
add these SSH keys to our grains
first. Oh, sure.
And, yes, you're right. Let's create a let's
create a home directory.
Let me spell things correctly.
Okay. So let's refresh.
Oh, the front of refresh command.
Salt, util,
thank all.
So
let's just run it on master
star
and
accurate
metadata
SSH.
Oh,
we now have that available as green data.
So
you want to provision a new user,
and we'll create a new we'll use our
livestream state, but we'll use a substate. So
let's call this user
Matt.
So what would you like to call this
new user?
Should match
yeah. Should call it ad. Yeah. We got
no.
I think
there is a user a
present
module.
Name
let's just confirm that. So we go back
to our state module list
user.
Move down a bit. User.
Yeah. It's user.
Yep. We have access
to this syntax. So we will copy it
as an example, tweak as needed. So let's
see. We've got name. Add.
If you bash.
Sure.
I'll give you a home directory
from UID
from UID.
There. How does that look?
Perfect.
Okay. So let's
run this.
It dot SLS
livestream
user
and
No group exists.
Yeah. We do not have
a will group.
You're getting no groups, I'm afraid. I'm removing
your group. Okay.
That's fair enough.
Just says failed to create.
I wonder
Do we have a
ID
match?
Good question. I was also wondering if maybe
there's a minimum number of catches for a
username. I can't remember. No.
No. I've I've successfully been in before.
Alright.
I mean, I don't see a thousand and
one user.
No. I don't either.
So
uh-huh. Let's try.
How to bug?
Oh, it's just that.
Why you fail? Why you fail? Why you
fail?
I mean, that's a pretty simple
It's a present. I'm gonna remove the
Can get it down to its minimum.
Alright. Okay. If I remove the UID and
GID, it worked. I'm
not sure why.
Much Oh, you know, I know what it
is. It's a YAML thing.
Oh, no.
Do they have to be quoted? Because it's
interpreting them as Octal or something stupid.
Yeah. I I I know it does that
with some weird numbers and format. Anyway, we're
we're good.
Okay. You're you're not a user. So l
s home
ID at
you exist. So Okay.
Next up, we want to provision
SSH keys.
Is that right? Yep.
And we're gonna do this at
home
at
dot s s h authorized
as single secret path.
Yeah. Think so.
We need to
no.
We
we need to enable template first,
didn't you?
Now we could do source like we did
last time.
However, our source is really just
those keys.
Believe we could just do contents.
We can use YAML multilane.
I think we make our way with the
Oh.
I think.
I can't remember. Do you remember what the
permissions need to be?
The directory needs to be
I'm just making up. I might be wrong.
700?
It can't be writable.
Alright.
Let's run this and see what happens.
Let's just Do it again.
So we got broken. Broken. Broken. Broken.
Okay. It's not leaking that. Doesn't like the
multi one.
Okay.
Grain. Got a packet. Yeah. That'll do that.
Oh, it's it's doesn't like Okay.
That that was fine.
This is wrong.
And
it's because okay. So there's I I'm gonna
assume I've got this understanding in my head
right, but I may be wrong. There are
two ways to reference Grain and Salt. So
we can do Grain's dot packet metadata, which
works for simple keys,
but this is a this is a complex
key. But I believe what we actually need
to do
is grains packet,
metadata,
SSH
keys,
like so.
Yeah. Okay. I think.
Didn't like the
It didn't like me not closing my Just
the sentence.
But I was just messing her braces.
Alright.
It does not have oh, okay. So, yeah,
when we use the complex syntax,
I think it actually
breaks it up. Like, I can't even remember
now. I'm completely making this up. Let's see.
Okay.
So better. I definitely did the interpolation,
but
it failed because
it did the interpolation.
Expected a semi
expected
a colon.
So this is just my multiline syntax, and
I think the problem is this array style
thing.
Okay.
So can I confirm what I think the
problem is?
Because YAML supports
supports YAML.
Syntax. Yeah. It's a YAML thing.
Let's
see if we can pull up a YAML
file there. Are you okay for time? Or
actually Yeah. I'm good. I'm good.
Alright. So what we have
we'll we'll copy it.
There's something like
so I'm
not sure what that copied.
I think copied
public keys.
I'll do it this way.
Alright.
I'll type it. Thanks.
Do we have something like that where we're
using this syntax here and
I could do this
shimmer.
I think I said that's something more if
I don't have one.
And if we validate this
Could not find
Oh, it is completing.
So my multiline syntax is wrong.
Maybe it needs to be indent a little
bit more.
I'm undented.
Yeah.
So
So I need to see if we did.
So we still have one problem here, though,
which we'll see in just a second.
Okay.
If I go to four Something something worked.
K.
It half worked.
And the problem is
we still have a No. That needs to
be
yeah. Because that's that's
Yep.
Just the wrong syntax.
So the good thing about the Genga things
is we have access to the entire Genga
templating library too.
So I think we can do join.
I think
we can do join with a new line.
Actually, it worked.
But the indentation's wrong. You can see there's
no erase and text. The Right.
Okay. So that means we need to do
one more thing.
And then
six.
We should end down every lane by six.
Didn't like it. Oh, that it oh, it
didn't end up.
What have I got wrong now?
Maybe it's eight.
Yeah.
Success. Hey. Wow.
Love me some yum. Much better. Okay. K.
It's got blank lines in there, but I
don't think that's gonna matter.
Well,
I'm not gonna ask you if you know
what your SSH key looks like, but I
believe you are in this project. So why
don't I believe so. Do you wanna share
your screen and see if you can connect
just to complete? Let me let me make
sure that I have
the right screen up.
Bring up PuTTY
because I have a fantastic Windows machine here.
And then the host name I'm connecting to
is?
1 4 7
Dot 70 5
Dot 30 3
Dot 1 3 4.
And let's see if I do the right
SSH key off.
Okay.
That was menu one.
I'm not touching it.
I'm waiting on I'm
waiting on me too.
It's not working.
That's
Well, let's let's well, let's see.
I mean, it's not terribly important,
I guess. I don't even know if your
SSH key is on that metadata. So and
it's just a buffer. No. I think I
think this is a
I think this is a something else going
on here. So let me
I'm switching to an off screen computer.
And what's the what's the
address again?
Dot 75
Dot 33
Dot 134.
Permission denied public key.
No. I wonder if that's because I made
up the
permissions on this file.
Yeah. I think you need to be 600
on that.
We can tell by taking a look at
the log.
Well, if I pull up
system menu log,
I don't think we got an SSH deny
message.
What can I look at?
Dash x v.
Yeah. I'm not really
oh, that's the wrong machine.
Oh.
There we go. So I was trying to
get the user
Could not find
No.
The pager.
I don't if that's after that. Alright. We
we got past that bit.
That's my IP address. That's me.
I bet yeah.
I bet it's a file permission thing.
Yeah. Either that or my key isn't in
the system.
That's not a big deal. That would've been
cool. Anyway,
we've covered a lot of salt there.
Is there anything we have missed, do you
think?
Is there any questions you've got? Anything
I we we've covered a lot. The the
whole idea of
using configuration
on the master
derived
from either the master or the minions
data.
Right? So we covered grains and how you
can interpolate grains into files.
The the
the neat thing about Salt for me is
just
how powerful it is for ad hoc commands.
Right?
If you if you've
if you know that you, for instance, need
like we did before, like, you know you
need to have j q in all the
machines,
That's a one liner, very easy to do,
very straightforward,
very simple.
It
for for me, Salt
is really two things. It's a very complex,
very powerful,
all consuming,
do everything with its system,
or it's a very simple,
do a couple of things very easily kind
of system.
Well, I think that's
that's a, you know, a couple different sources
of usefulness
for it.
Yeah.
Definitely.
I mean,
I I completely agree with that. So, you
know, give that a big massive thumbs up.
I think, you know, when you're dealing with
the the ability to run out of commands
against all your machines or a subset of
your machines is just really important.
But even that, I think Salt has a
lot of power even on a single machine
setup. Just the ability to automate all of
these things. Like, you know, I can do
Salt command dot run, but, you know, putting
together state files like this makes something really,
really repeatable.
Yeah.
They made so much so I use it
for my doc files, as I kinda mentioned
earlier. So that's Yeah. It's just yeah. And
for that, we're powerful
and fast. You know, I don't think we've
really ever waited too long and anything happening,
which is nice.
And and small enough,
to consider on small machines.
I'm actively using it on a Pi three,
which has got one gigabyte of memory and
it you know, the the baseline load of
what does it take to run it,
doesn't show up very much.
Yeah. And and it does not have massive
footprint CPU or memory wise, which is great.
And super
I mean, it's pretty tweakable and configurable as
well. Yeah. Definitely.
I'm just trying to think if there's anything
we should cover or if we just leave
it there and maybe we'll do a second
session another day.
I think we can leave it there. I
mean, the the
the,
key management is really
something if you're bringing up a lot of
machines. I think,
understanding,
like, what does it take to take a
machine online or offline.
But, yeah, I think we can we can
leave it there. We we we've covered a
lot of ground.
That's really, really helpful, really useful.
Awesome. Well, thank you for joining me today.
It's been a a pleasure going through some
of this stuff and chatting with you. And
I hope that we can do this again
soon. So thank you again. I'm looking forward
to it. Alright. Have a nice day. Hey.
Take care.